What's the topic of today's video?
No, that's far too general.
No, it's not that either.
No, I already made a video on that one.
Yes, that's it.
Hello, everyone. Welcome to the
Langfocus channel, and my name is Paul.
Today, I'm going to talk
about the Russian language.
Why is Russian important?
Well, Russian is one of the
world's major languages.
It is one of the six official
languages of the United Nations,
and it is the eighth most widely
spoken language in the world
with around 155
million native speakers
and around 260
million speakers in total,
if we include second language speakers.
It's an official language
in Russia, of course,
but also in Belarus, Tajikistan,
Kyrgyzstan and Kazakhstan.
It is also an official language
in 38 other unrecognized states,
autonomous territories, and regions
in Ukraine, Moldova and Georgia,
and also a few localities in Romania,
and the Russian Economic Zone
in Spitsbergen in Norway.
It is also widely spoken as a second
language and a lingua franca
throughout much of Central Asia, the
Caucasus region and in Eastern Europe.
Even in a lot of places where
it is not an official language.
That's why Russian is important.
Russian is the most widely spoken
language of the Slavic language family.
Have a look at my video on the
Slavic language family, here,
to learn more about it in detail.
But, in brief,
the Slavic languages are a branch of
the Indo-European language family,
and the beginning of the Slavic
language branch traces back
to a language called Proto-Slavic
which existed around 500 CE.
Over the next few hundred years,
Proto-Slavic split into three varieties:
West Slavic, South Slavic and East Slavic.
Which eventually diverged into branches
of the Slavic language family,
containing numerous languages each.
Russian is an East Slavic language
along with Belarusian,
Ukrainian and also Rusyn.
At the time that these
three branches developed,
there was a single Slavic literary
language that all Slavs could understand.
That language was Old Church Slavonic.
Russian is written in the Cyrillic script,
which was created for the purpose
of writing Old Church Slavonic.
Until the 14th century,
the ancestors of modern day
Russians, Ukrainians and Belarusians,
living in a state called Kievan Rus
spoke dialects of Old East Slavic.
This spoken language existed alongside the
literary language of Old Church Slavonic,
a situation of diglossia.
There is, however, some evidence
that people used to write
in the spoken vernacular for
some kinds of casual writing.
Birch bark letters from the town
of Novogorod in the 14th century
are written in the vernacular language
and the concern topics of daily life.
Old Church Slavonic, however,
was the literary and religious language.
In the 13th century, Kievan Rus
was conquered by the Mongol Empire
which brought a lot of foreign Turkic
loanwords into the East Slavic dialects,
especially words related to
political and financial matters.
After the end of Mongol
rule in the 14th century,
the Old East Slavic area was
split into two separate states,
the Grand Duchy of Moscow to the east,
and the Grand Duchy of Lithuania
to the west
in the general area of
Ukraine, Belarus, and Lithuania.
the oldest Slavic dialects
in those two states
began to split and develop
in different directions.
In the west, the Ruthenian language
emerged with heavy Polish influence.
Ruthenian dialects would later develop
into Ukrainian and Belarusian.
In the east, Russian emerged with much
more influence from Old Church Slavonic.
Modern Russian today resulted
from a kind of tug-of-war
between Old Church Slavonic,
on the one hand,
and the vernacular spoken dialects,
on the other hand.
For example, in 1453 CE after
the fall of the Byzantine Empire,
Byzantine and Bulgarian scholars
began moving to Moscow,
and they were upset that Old Church
Slavonic had become corrupted or Russified,
and they tried to standardize the
language to remove these "impurities".
So, a unique Russian language
had begun to emerge,
but scholars pulled the language
back towards Old Church Slavonic.
But, then during the rule of
Peter the Great from 1696 to 1725,
the written language was
pulled in a different direction
away from Old Church Slavonic.
In order to increase literacy,
he simplified the orthography
of the written language,
eliminating some letters
and some diacritics.
He also made great efforts to
modernize and westernize Russia,
and started to orient
Russia towards Europe,
and French became the common language
of the upper classes in Russia.
As you might guess,
this resulted in the adoption of
some French loanwords into Russian.
He also oversaw the intentional adoption
of specialized modern vocabulary
from various European languages
like French, Dutch and German.
Peter the Great's reforms
were some of the first steps
in the development of
modern literary Russian,
the basis of standard Russian today.
Another influential person in the
development of modern literary Russian
was Mikhail Lomonosov
In 1755, he wrote a grammar
of the Russian language,
which revolutionized the written language
by combining Old Church Slavonic
with the spoken language.
Throughout the grammar,
he refers to Old Church Slavonic
as the language of High style,
and he refers to the spoken language
as the language of Low style,
and he advocated a blended Middle
style for most forms of writing.
The High style was basically
reserved for religious texts
and the Low style was reserved for
the most casual written material.
In the following decades, authors and
poets developed a new middle style
that would form the core of
Modern Standard Russian.
The most influential was
the poet Alexander Pushkin,
who was sometimes referred to as
the father of the modern Russian language.
He fully developed the idea of
three different language registers,
high, middle and low,
making the spoken vernacular a
legitimate part of the language.
He also greatly expanded the
vocabulary of literary Russian
by directly translating phrases
and idioms from other languages.
He greatly influenced
modern literary Russian,
and as a result Modern Standard Russian
which formed during this time
based on the literary language.
In the 20th century, Russian underwent
some small changes mainly in orthography.
But, by far the most important thing
to happen to the language
was the creation of the Soviet empire.
Universal schooling and the mass
media spread modern Standard Russian
and reduced dialectal variation in Russian.
It also spread the language
over a vast geographic area,
covering all the member states of the USSR.
Today, Russian is still widely
spoken in all of those areas,
and is a common lingua franca
between different ethnic groups,
and between the citizens
of different countries.
So, what is Russian like?
Orthography.
Russian is written in the Cyrillic script,
an alphabet consisting of 33 letters which
were mostly developed from Greek letters.
Some are the same as letters
of the Latin alphabet,
but some of the sounds they
represent are different,
like this one.
Phonology.
There are 21 consonants in Russian,
but 15 of them can be pronounced in two
different ways either hard or soft,
and you have to judge which sound
to make by looking at the letter
that comes after the consonant.
The soft sound is palletized,
meaning that part of your tongue
reaches the roof of your mouth.
This makes the consonant kind of sound
like it's followed by a Y sound.
Here are some examples.
bak - byak
bek - byek
mal - myal
per - pyer
sak - syak
Phonology.
There are six basic vowels in Russian,
but there's a lot of
variation in the vowels
depending on the surrounding sounds and
based on the stress pattern of the word.
Vowels are often reduced when they
appear in an unstressed syllable,
this can make it a challenge to pronounce
words correctly based on their spelling
Grammar.
Russian is a fusional language,
meaning that suffixes and prefixes
are added to root words to
communicate grammatical meaning.
Let's look at nouns, first.
There are six noun cases in Russian
meaning that both the singular
and the plural form of a noun
can take six different forms depending on
the grammatical function in the sentence.
Let's look at an example
using the word for sister.
Nominative case: sestra.
Sestra chitayet -
"The sister reads".
Genitive case: sestry.
YA znayu imya sestry -
"I know the sister's name".
Dative case: sestrye.
Brat dal sestrye bilyet -
"The brother gave the sister a ticket".
Accusative case: sestru.
Brat vidit sestru -
"The brother sees the sister".
Instrumental case: sestroy.
YA zhivu s sestroy -
"I live with the sister".
Prepositional case: sestrye.
Na sestrye -
"On the sister".
On the side note, it's interesting
to notice the cognate vocabulary
between Russian and English and
some other Indo-European languages.
"sestra" is sister
"brat" is brother
"bilyet" is ticket
and even the word for 'see' "vidit"
reminds me of the Italian word
"vedere" which means 'to see'.
So, here we see some clear indications of
Russian being an Indo-European language.
Now, back to the noun cases.
The case endings are different
depending on the gender of the noun.
Russian nouns are grouped
according to gender
with masculine, feminine,
and neuter nouns.
You can normally tell the nouns
gender based on its ending.
Feminine nouns can take
either of these endings.
Neuter nouns can take
And masculine nouns are the nouns
ending in any other letter.
The one tricky exception is that
some nouns end in this letter,
and these can be either
masculine or feminine,
so you need to memorize
the gender of those ones.
Adjectives.
Adjectives and Russian
are quite complicated.
They are inflected to agree with the noun
they modify, in gender, number and in case,
That means that any particular adjectives
can have 24 different forms.
Like this.
Wow.
Let's look at a couple of examples,
This is the adjective meaning "new".
In the nominative case:
novvy - Eto novyy avtomobil'
This is a new car.
In the genitive case:
novogo - tsvet novogo avtomobilya
The new car's color.
So, we can see how the ending
of the adjectives changes
to make it agree with the noun.
But, it's worth noting,
that the inflectional endings
added to the adjectives
are different from those added to the noun,
So, you need to memorize a big set of
endings for nouns and when to use them,
but you have to memorize a whole
different set of endings for adjectives
and when to use those.
Verbs.
The Russian language has three
verb tenses: past, present and future.
That sounds straightforward,
but Russian verbs are also distinguished
based on something called aspect.
There's the perfective aspect which means
that an action has been completed once
Then, there's the imperfective aspect
which shows that the action is
still in progress, still ongoing,
or that it's an action that will be
recurring, will be repeated many times.
In Russian verb,
there are two different verb stems
for the imperfective and the perfective
aspect, basically like two different words.
Let's look at an example for
the verb meaning to write.
First the perfective: napisa.
And the imperfective: pisa.
Either of these stems can be conjugated
for past, present and future tenses.
Let's look at an example of how aspect
changes the meaning of a sentence.
This sentence uses the verb
with the perfective verb stem
and is in the future tense
YA napishu knigu
This sentence means
"I will write a book",
but when we take the aspect
into account the meaning is
"I will write one specific book",
an action that will be completed.
This next sentence uses the imperfective
verb stem, and is also in the future tense
YA budu pisat' knigu
The meaning of this one is more like
"I will be writing a book",
in other words "I will be in
the process of writing a book",
at a certain time in the future.
Or, if we use the plural form of book
then the meaning changes,
it means "I will write books"
YA budu pisat' knigi
and that means
"I will write numerous books",
a recurring action.
So, in that case the imperfective aspect
indicates a slightly different meaning
Basic word order.
The most common word order
in Russian is SVO,
but because of the case system
the word order is much more
flexible than it is in English.
In English, we normally
judge the function of a word,
depending on where it is in the sentence.
But, in Russian, we have the case system.
The case endings can tell us
the function of the word.
So, you can move the words around
and we still understand what the subject
is, what the object is, and so on.
So, a basic sentence might be:
Koshka poymala mysh',
meaning the cat caught the mouse.
But, you can also have:
Mysh' poymala koshka,
or: poymala koshka mysh'
and some other possible word order.
So, the basic word order
is flexible like that
However, in some cases
the context or the style
that you are trying to communicate
in will determine the word order
Articles.
Like most Slavic languages, Russian
doesn't have any articles,
it doesn't have words like 'a' or 'the'.
If you have any Russian speaking riends,
who drop the articles when
they're speaking English,
that's probably the reason.
So, how hard is Russian to learn?
Well, according to the
American Foreign Service Institute,
Russian is a category IV language.
The most difficult
category is category V,
and that includes Japanese,
Mandarin, and Arabic.
But, Russian is in category IV,
that means that it's relatively
difficult for English speakers,
but not the most difficult.
The most challenging things will likely
be the inflection of nouns and adjectives,
as well as the system of verbal aspect.
Some people mistakenly assume
that the Cyrillic alphabet
is going to be the most challenging
part of learning Russian,
but people actually learn that
fairly quickly once they start.
Russian is a major global language
that will be very useful to you
if you spend any time in Russia or
in any of the former Soviet republics,
so your efforts will be well rewarded.
So, the question of the day.
For people who have studied Russian:
What did you find challenging about Russian
and what did you find
straightforward about Russian?
And, for native speakers of Russian:
Russia is a huge country,
do you notice a lot of variation
in the way that Russian is spoken in
different parts of the countries?
Are there noticeable accents
or dialects these days?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow Langfocus on Twitter,
on Facebook, and on Instagram.
And, thank you to all
my patreon supporters.
You guys continue to be great
and I appreciate you.
Thank you for watching,
and have a nice day!